welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host and today
i have the great pleasure of being
joined by greg knuckles he is currently
the permanent guest co-host for the time
being greg
how are you doing today i'm doing well
how are you i am doing great uh we have
a lot of great topics to cover in
today's episode but before we get to
that
if you enjoy the podcast and you'd like
to support it there are many ways you
could do that you could like rate or
subscribe wherever you get podcasts you
could join our email newsletter by going
to strongerbyscience.com
newsletter you could use our discount
code at bulksupplements.com
the code is sbs pod and that gets you a
five percent discount off of your order
you could subscribe to the mass research
review which we are both co-authors of
or finally you could check out macro
factor which is the diet app that we
developed it does have a free trial so
if you want to take it for a spin and
see if you like it there is no risk
involved uh road to the stage greg how's
it going uh road to the stage is going
well uh it was supposed to be put on
paul's over this over this past uh
half a week or so um
took a little trip with uh with lindsay
just you know a bit of time to to chill
out decompress etc uh
wasn't tracking food i wasn't working
out just chilling just you know trying
to eat mindfully not completely fall off
the wagon and uh yeah went better than i
anticipated it to uh
got back last night woke up today
at a new at a new all-time low weight so
uh
yeah still still chugging along uh even
though i did not expect it to be so
oh overall things are pretty good so
what do you attribute that to do you
think it was just kind of staying active
and staying busy
combined with a little bit of mindful
eating
yeah yeah i think so yeah yeah i i
always tend to find that whenever i'm uh
dieting if i can find a you know if i
have a weekend or a week here or there
where i'm just super busy and my my
brain is on activities rather than food
and i'm moving around all day uh yeah
sometimes you have these nice little
surprises so nice to see
yes sir uh so on the road to athens on
my side of things uh nothing new i'm
really enjoying training a lot which is
kind of
you know for a while there you know if
you stick with training long enough you
have your ups and downs where sometimes
you're just going through the motions
and sometimes you're really enthusiastic
and enjoying it
so for the first time in
actually quite a while i'm really
enjoying training which is fun uh i did
have a minor like very very minor
setback where i noticed that i kind of
aggravated some of my symptoms um i kind
of went off script and did a bunch of
stuff that i maybe wasn't necessarily
supposed to do um but that's not
necessarily a bad thing like if you can
test your this definitely isn't advice
but you know for me personally if i test
my boundaries a little bit and i get a
little slap on the wrist you know just a
little bit of aggravation but not you
know anything major i think it can be
helpful to kind of learn those
boundaries so that you can readjust and
kind of reassess moving forward you know
if you never test those boundaries in
any way then sometimes you get stuck in
that cycle where you're just afraid of
movement and you're never trying new
things you're never trying to get back
into your normal training for sure uh so
there's a little bit of uh you know
there's kind of a fine line where
pushing those boundaries a little bit
within safe constraints is a good thing
uh but you know just being completely
reckless probably not a great thing when
you're trying to recover from something
so overall you know pretty happy about
it not a big deal
uh how about fits of strength what do we
got this week yeah so uh cpu nationals
uh is coming up soon that's the canadian
ipf powerlifting affiliate uh and in the
lead up to cpu nationals uh jessica
bittner has deadlifted 250 for a double
uh that's in kilos to 551 pounds and has
squatted uh 220 which is 484 485 if
memory serves uh
she currently holds the world records in
her weight class with a 210 squat and
250 deadlift so
it looks like she is primed to
potentially blow both of those numbers
out of the water
assuming her peak and everything goes
well which i fully expect it to
she is coached by frenemy of the pod
eric helms uh and
you know
it's nice that she's doing so well in
spite of that
that is true that is true
um
but to push back against that a little
bit uh you know eric knows how to to
bring people into a meet and peek them
well so you know all all of the stars
seem to be aligned for some huge numbers
out of her uh we're recording this on
monday cpu nationals is starting today
and i believe jessica's flight will go
on friday so the day after this episode
comes out um
so yeah if you're interested in
potentially seeing
a huge squat and deadlift world record
in the women's 76 kilo class uh tune in
and check that out
that's awesome and i'd like to add a
feat of strength this week
a huge major shout out to the tree next
to my house
just a really clutch and impressive feat
of strength so
uh we had a tornado watch for like six
hours the other day there was some nasty
storms that rolled through
and everything seemed fine you know no
big deal but i went out the next morning
and realized that one of the pine trees
in my yard like a full-grown pine tree
had just completely snapped in half and
looked like it had crushed my roof
but then upon further inspection
it appeared that a tree
that was kind of in the way
had like just barely cradled the fallen
trees so that it was like still touching
my house but like
man if that tree was a little shorter or
a little weaker the one that caught the
other tree yeah uh that that fallen pine
tree would have just like demolished my
home uh so i'm still not really sure
like the extent of the damage i got to
go up on the roof and figure out how we
did there but like the fact that my home
isn't like semi collapsed is is kind of
a miracle so absolutely huge shout out
to the tree that caught the other tree
in my side yard just a really impressive
feat of strength that that is pretty
clutch uh
one thing i'll note that maybe jessica
has over the tree in your yard
is that she is a macro factor affiliate
uh
she's been using that to to track and
manage her weight and nutrition
for
i think like the last six months at this
point uh but anyway if you want to
extend your free trial and show jessica
some love her uh affiliate code is
forklift enter that at checkout and you
can extend your one week free trial into
a two-week free trial
all right very good stuff
um so in terms of the hard-hitting
scientific content this week
i wanted to start out by talking a
little bit about fiber so just like a
really brief research review about fiber
because we've kind i think i've
mentioned this or alluded to it on the
show previously but
it's kind of unprecedented times when it
comes to fiber in the nutrition world
these days like
going back there were few things that
had almost unanimous and universal
acceptance in the nutrition world and
one of those very few things was like
hey fiber
pretty good pretty nice thing
uh but nowadays it's getting some
pushback you know like even when
even when keto had its its heyday when
it was getting huge at like you know
2012 to 2014
everybody in fitness was you know
uh becoming aware of it and becoming
intrigued by it even then a lot of the
keto recommendations were like you know
how much carb should i have and it's
like well you want to make sure you get
your fiber in so just have enough like
fibrous vegetables to take care of that
and you'll probably be about where you
need to be you know so even when keto
was really accelerating people were like
well wait a minute let's not blame all
carbs let's get all get our fiber in but
now that the carnivore diet is getting
more and more attention
it is
uh naturally coming with some uh
interesting claims about fiber right so
if you tell somebody hey like most if
not all of your diet should be coming
from you know
muscle tissue and other tissue of
animals
uh
intuitively or you know a natural
consequence of that is someone's gonna
say well hey what a what about fiber
yeah you know
and so you know you it's really
difficult to promote a carnivore diet
without having some kind of talking
points prepared where you can address
you know that
big uh gap in the diet which is where is
the fiber going to come from
so now more than ever you're seeing
stuff on the internet on social media in
particular suggesting that maybe fiber
isn't actually good
maybe there is no
reason related to health or wellness
to consume fiber in your diet maybe it's
completely unnecessary and i've even
seen i've seen some people take it as
far as to say
that
that dietary fiber might even have a net
negative impact when included in the
diet
so
people are seeing that more and more
interacting with it more and more
and you know i think a very natural
reaction is like wow that's so
surprising and so contradictory to
everything i've heard about fiber uh i
can't believe it and i agree
i cannot believe it uh it because it's
not really an evidence-based take so i
wanted to take a moment to kind of uh
just kind of highlight some of the
benefits of fiber in the diet i don't
want to belabor the point because i
think most people are already bought
into this but but it can induce a little
bit of uh
you know a little bit of confusion or
cognitive dissonance where on one half
of your
instagram feed you see all this positive
stuff about fiber and then on the other
half you see uh you know a bunch of
stuff saying oh actually fiber is pretty
bad and the reason i wanted to address
this was because i recently covered
fiber in a research review in in mass so
i was covering a review that was looking
at a fiber restricted diet
but it was specifically in the context
of a short-term weight cut so you could
imagine if you were cutting up that
those last few pounds before
uh a wrestling match or before a power
lifting meet or you know maybe even if
you wanted to do that before a physique
based competition
there are some applications of these
fiber restricted diets and we're talking
about taking your fiber down from you
know i think a lot of people in the
fitness world are in the 30 40 50 gram a
day range we're talking about taking
that all the way down to single digits
for
two three four maybe five days in a row
and so
there is research including the study i
reviewed in mass
within the last month or two indicating
that a short-term fiber-restricted diet
can be a helpful thing when it comes to
short-term weight cutting you know it's
not going to have a huge effect but you
might see
just a little bit of a drop in total
body mass which of course is to be
expected when you start restricting
fiber uh basically what happens is the
content of uh digested food stuff in
your gi tract goes down a little bit you
kind of clear out your system that's why
for certain gastrointestinal procedures
they will have you kind of restrict food
intake and fiber intake so that you can
basically clear out your system for for
various medical procedures and
diagnostic procedures um so so there's
really nothing new there but one of the
things that uh the researchers noted in
that study was
this is not a long-term dietary solution
so the fact that short-term you know two
three four five days of fiber
restriction the fact that that can be
implemented successfully for weight
cutting does not mean hey why don't you
just do that forever and stay a pound or
two lighter than normal in perpetuity
yeah um and so
just briefly like i'm gonna link a
couple review papers in the show notes
for people who want to dig into the
details like i said i don't want to
belabor the point because i feel like
i'm kind of preaching to the choir here
but there was a great review by anderson
and colleagues where they kind of
highlighted the research indicating that
high fiber intake is associated with
lower risk of coronary heart disease
stroke hypertension diabetes obesity and
certain gastrointestinal diseases
there is also a different review paper
by barber and colleagues where they
pointed out that fiber is inversely
associated with all-cause mortality
along with mortality from cardiovascular
disease and all cancers overall
and of course a lot of times people hear
that and they say okay correlation
association that's all observational
that's a bunch of crap
but there is a pretty strong mechanistic
mechanistic basis from randomized
controlled trials by which you can
really clearly draw a line
between a causative mechanism that is
reliably induced by high fiber intake
and the types of outcomes that we're
seeing in these studies so
when it comes to fiber it is a very
strong and very comprehensive case for
the fact that fiber by and large has a
very positive impact in the diet and if
you're wondering what an advisable
intake for fiber might be a very basic
recommendation that you see all the time
is about 14 grams of fiber per thousand
calories in the diet so for a 2000
calorie diet that would be 28 grams of
fiber per day for example
and the reason that they scale that
recommendation to caloric intake is
because
as anyone who's done some pretty
restrictive dieting has observed
it can be really hard to get high fiber
intake on a very low calorie diet
i still try my best to do that um like
you know if i'm down on a you know 15
1800 calorie diet i do try to get higher
than that 14 per thousand calorie number
um just to try to stay close to my
typical fiber intake uh but without
question it gets very very challenging
because where there's fiber you're
usually going to find other
non-fiber carbohydrate that's going to
come with it so when you start cutting
carbs and total calories out of your
diet a lot of times you will see that
the fiber tends to go with it a little
bit
but yeah i mean fiber is is really
fascinating in terms of its impact on a
variety of different health outcomes
and there's even some less obvious
associations that have been observed so
some studies have found that fiber
intake is associated with better immune
function lower chronic inflammation
levels and even a lower risk of
depression and those are some of the
outcomes where it gets a little bit
harder to draw a really strong
mechanistic link but i do think one
fascinating kind of
related area of research is in the realm
of short chain fatty acids so when we
consume dietary fiber
and other non-digestible or partially
digestible carbohydrates
when those start to ferment in the
digestion process
what we see is that they
they do lead to the production of
several different short chain fatty
acids and other associated metabolites
and those short chain fatty acids and
similar metabolites
they do seem to have some pretty wide
ranging physiological effects that we
are
in the process of elucidating and fully
starting to understand but we're really
not there yet uh so i remember a few
years back i dug into the research on
short chain fatty acids and uh it's a
very very fascinating body of literature
but it it's kind it kind of reminds me a
bit of if you were to dig into the gut
microbiome literature right now you can
see the glimpses of like okay this is
definitely important
in in some capacity but the question is
how do we make that useful how do we act
upon that yeah and for what things is it
truly causative so there's there's much
to be learned there but
basically what i wanted to do with this
segment was uh kind of highlight the
fact that uh you've not lost your mind
despite what you're seeing more and more
on social media fiber
within the academic world and within the
world of anyone working clinically in
nutrition fiber is still embraced as a
very very uh healthful addition to the
diet within the types of intakes that
i've described yeah
now one thing i should acknowledge
is that there are some instances with
certain gut-related pathologies and
clinical conditions where short-term
fiber reduction is part of the treatment
process so if you go in to seek medical
treatment for
certain specific gastrointestinal
conditions
they might for a time put you on a
pretty restrictive diet that eliminates
a lot of fibrous foods
but when you look into the clinical
literature about those types of
interventions it's almost always framed
as a short-term elimination diet with
the purpose
where you you do that elimination diet
you remove foods that could be
exacerbating symptoms and once you reach
a point where symptoms have subsided you
start reintroducing foods and generally
building fiber back up to a tolerable
level yeah so a lot of people have
looked into some of these short term
interventions of fiber restriction and
said oh man if fiber's so bad for your
gut i'm just going to restrict it all
the time
and that would be a misapplication of
that research and generally an
inadvisable thing to do
especially if you already have
an otherwise
healthy functioning gi system with no
symptoms yeah yeah i mean that's like
saying uh super strenuous exercise is
contraindicated immediately following a
heart attack therefore
no one should ever do strenuous exercise
yeah exactly it's it's a complete
misapplication and and one other thing
i'll note uh just before you move on
because i see what's coming up next in
the outline
um
is i feel like i feel like this is a
topic where
you know let's assume
that the skeptics are correct and that
it is just pure that it is mere
correlation there's no causative factors
whatsoever um
you know and it and it is what it is i
still feel like even in even in a
situation like that and i'm not saying
that that's what i believe to be the
case i'm just saying like let's play
devil's advocate and assume that is true
if you tell someone uh you know hey try
to get more fiber in your diet um
and especially if you generally promote
uh trying to get you know most of your
nutrition in from whole food sources
then you just ask like well okay what uh
what dietary changes would they
potentially be making and then it's like
well let's just look at what foods have
a lot of fiber like
lots of fibrous vegetables most fruits
most seeds nuts stuff like that like
things that are
you know generally understood and
believed to have
other health promoting effects and so
you know
even if this is just mere correlation
where it's like oh well it turns out
that a lot of the people who eat a lot
of fiber are also
you know
it's it's because they're eating a lot
of these other foods and maybe like some
other nutrients in the foods are having
the positive effects not the fiber per
se
then you know i feel like you could you
could potentially hit a pothole with the
fiber recommendation if someone's like
oh well okay i'll just keep eating the
way i'm currently eating but just take
some psyllium husk but if they're going
to be getting the fiber in mostly from
whole food sources
uh aiming for fiber intake can kind of
work just as a general heuristic that
would
promote other just generally beneficial
dietary patterns whether or not fiber is
the causative factor so i think that um
you know i i do think fiber in and of
itself is having an independent positive
effect but even if i didn't i still
don't know that the fiber recommendation
wouldn't still be a good recommendation
to give yeah that's an important
clarification i kind of mentioned that
in the mass article but i forgot to
bring it up in this segment but it's
definitely true and it reminds me of
like whenever i talk about dietary
nitrate uh
i usually recommend getting it from food
from plant sources rather than dietary
supplements and usually what i say is
listen this research isn't fully
conclusive yet for performance benefits
um but let's say you take my advice and
you start eating more spinach and
arugula and celery and beets and maybe a
little bit of pomegranate
you're better off like you're you're in
a good spot there like there's all
upside and no downside uh when it comes
to that shift in dietary pattern and the
same thing is true if you tell somebody
hey you know try to get at least 14
grams per thousand calories try to get
it from
whole food sources
it's
very very likely that they're going to
be adopting a more uh health-promoting
dietary pattern whether or not the
dietary fiber has a damn thing to do
with it so that's a really important
clarification for sure
um and yeah like
like i said it's not like we're just
looking
at these observational findings and
saying well we have no idea what's going
on but it looks good for you know
diabetes or heart disease or whatever
the case may be i mean we do have the
randomized controlled trials indicating
improvements in glycemic control
improvements in blood
blood lipid profiles i mean
this is a real
in a world of nutrition research where
it's hard to find really comprehensive
bodies of literature where everything
seems to add up
fiber is one of those things where you
can make some pretty safe bets with
fiber
so getting ahead of a few claims some
specific claims that you might see out
there number one like i mentioned a lot
of people are saying that fiber isn't
necessary and a lot of times they frame
that by saying fiber is not essential in
the dietary context and when we talk
about something being
essential for nutrition that basically
means your body can't make it you need
to get it from food in order to function
uh
in a healthy way right so like if for
example
if you are severely lacking an essential
fatty acid or an essential amino acid
that is going to down the line lead to
pathological states uh you know where
where you have clinical clinically
relevant negative outcomes due to that
uh that deficiency
uh now with fiber it is not
essential in that context you are not
going to acutely die
from a fiber deficiency it's simply not
going to happen but like i said
not acutely dying from a deficiency
is one thing
but it's a completely different thing to
say what is a healthy you know
health-promoting dietary pattern that
seems to be compatible with reducing my
risk of mortality and various chronic
diseases and so you could not say that
fiber restriction is going to acutely
kill you due to deficiency but you
definitely can make a very strong case
that seeking an appropriate amount of
fiber in the diet is going to be
correlated with a lot of very positive
health outcomes
when compared to a lower fiber intake
number two i've seen a lot of people
sharing a couple specific studies
indicating that fiber does not always
cure constipation so like there's a
couple randomizer there's a couple um
papers where they do a high fiber
intervention in patients who are
experiencing constipation at baseline
and they're just trying to say like hey
is this a super reliable treatment
intervention for this specific uh
presentation of constipation uh but it's
important to remember there are two very
different questions that relate to this
so first
you might ask is increasing fiber a
reliable treatment intervention for
intractable cases of constipation so
people who have tried the
over-the-counter stuff and they're like
man i just can't you know i can't
sort out this constipation the symptoms
are very persistent that's one question
but another question is
what happens to fecal consistency and
bowel movement frequency when a healthy
asymptomatic person intentionally
restricts their fiber
and the reason i bring up these two
different questions is because a lot of
people who do not have persistent
intractable constipation are using these
intervention studies to say see fiber
doesn't even help you poop anyway right
but what we see in the studies so for
example the study i recently reviewed in
mass is when the individuals did this
aggressive fiber restriction in this
study
in a controlled setting
what we saw was
a shift in stool hardness that was uh
very consistent with constipation
symptoms a reduction in bowel movement
frequency and a shift in stool type
using a specific scale i think it's
called the bristol stool scale where you
can kind of look at pictures and say
yeah my poop looks like that one it's
numbered i think one through seven or
something like that so
when we take a healthy person who is not
experiencing constipation who's just
kind of having their normal habitual
fiber intake and we encourage them to
intentionally restrict it we do see
unfavorable changes in fecal consistency
stool type and bowel movement frequency
generally all trending toward a cluster
of changes that are
fairly consistent with mild constipation
symptoms so it's really important not to
take some of those intervention studies
out of context and apply them in a
completely different context
the final thing i want to mention
when you see some of these claims about
fiber being useless or even deleterious
usually you'll see claims about how
plants are just generally bad because
they have compounds that are intended to
deter pr predators from eating them uh
and that is true plants have
uh you know
certain compounds that are there to try
to deter predators from threatening
their ability to exist that makes sense
from an evolutionary perspective and so
people will kind of make these points
like dude you're literally eating lethal
poisons that are intended to kill you if
you eat this stuff
and like if you were an insect
that would be very troubling but as a
human being
not quite as scary because like what
we're talking about here is a nice spicy
meal capsaicin is thought to be one of
those compounds that deters predators
from eating uh certain plants
humans can eat spicy foods it's not a
big deal it doesn't kill us
coffee has caffeine a similar type of
thing coffee very lovely it's a nice
beverage uh terkesterone everyone's
favorite
literally causes insects to melt
like it is
like the most disastrous instance of
this yeah it forces them to molt
themselves to death yeah and to shed
their skin before they have or to shed
their exoskeleton before they have a new
exoskeleton
ready to go so they just their their
insides become their outsides yeah
it literally causes them to
spontaneously melt and fall apart and
die uh so it's a nasty way to go it just
kills me that on the two sides of the
fitness industry right now i'm hearing
some people say like oh man these plant
toxins are so scary and other people are
like dude if you're not taking
terkestrone what are you even doing yeah
and it's like there there's no way to
make these two different sides
compatible
um and one of the things i mentioned is
kind of like a i was kind of like
facetiously mocking this argument and i
was like what's next are you gonna say
that tea is bad because like you know
tea has caffeine and it's the same kind
of thing as coffee like uh the
evolutionary origin of caffeine
has been proposed to be to deter
predators from consuming these plants
and then i literally saw a carnivore
person with a huge following saying like
yeah dude avoid tea it's really bad news
was it that video of like sean sean
baker in a like whole foods with his
shirt off
no it was uh it was or
wait no it was uh i think saladino yeah
yeah yeah saladino yeah that's right and
like dude
it
to suggest that tea is deleterious for
health like to the point that you should
call out like hey make sure you avoid
tea
it's just it's not
simply a not evidence-based take
it is a full and complete rejection of
all available evidence about tea yeah
tea has been widely studied its effects
are
virtually unanimously neutral to
positive on long-term health outcomes
the idea that it's something to be
feared is
honestly a bit silly
so that is my uh long
lecture about fiber and in fact
everything that you believe to be true
about fiber is in fact true
yeah i mean
i wonder if this is a long game to uh
to like convince people that no i'm not
a bad cook i'm just trying to be healthy
because most uh most like
aromatics and herbs um aren't aren't
poison to plants but are
uh there to deter uh or aren't poisoned
insects but are there to deter insects
like yeah you know that's a thing you
can do like in your yard or your garden
you can if there's a place where you
want people to be able to sit outside
and not be messed with by insects uh you
can just like plant a circle of aromatic
herbs around them and that will do
a decent job of keeping insects away for
that reason so like you know
i wonder if these people are like ah man
i don't i don't know how spices work uh
what if i just tell everyone that i'm
just trying to not poison them and
that's that's how i can get out of
ever having to learn how to cook well i
mean that's the thing is like
i am
hurting myself by taking this position i
would love to say yeah spices
bad news it's a terrible thing don't get
into it because that would justify
everything i've ever said about cooking
but in the interest of intellectual
honesty i gotta say i don't think it's a
strong point and uh yeah it's just it's
getting a little bit silly to me
um but anyway moving on greg i noticed
that you had some things in the q a
section that you wanted to uh to make
note of here yeah yeah so these aren't
questions from particular people it's
mostly just responding to questions and
feedback that have come
after a couple of my recent segments um
so yeah i just just wanted to uh clear
some things up so in the most recent
episode before this one i had a segment
talking about the effects of oral
contraception on uh strength and
hypertrophy outcomes um you know
basically coming down on the side of hey
when you look at all of the research
there are people out there saying that
if you take
hormonal contraceptives that's going to
have a negative impact on strength and
muscle growth but
the human evidence just doesn't back
that up there's no reliable evidence
that that is the case um
and there's you know there's
quite a few studies done at this point
like 10 papers from eight individual
studies if if memory serves and
you just can't make an evidence-based
case for
oral contraception uh having a negative
impact on strength and hypertrophy
outcomes like the the human data just
don't support that position um
and so there have been
so i i've seen a sentiment expressed a
few times
that i was
promoting oral contraceptives and i i
want to make my
intentions behind that segment clear
um
so oral contraceptives are medication
and as with any medication that's
something for you and your doctor to
talk about and there there are many
things that you might want to talk about
potential side effects uh you know just
generally how it's going to make you
feel different options that might uh you
know fit your lifestyle better etc um
you know there's a ton of stuff to talk
about and i am simply
in favor of when people are making
decisions helping them make the most
informed decisions possible
and so you know i'm i'm not going to
tell anyone to take or not take oral
contraceptives but
one
one concern i have
is that when you have that conversation
with your doctor there's going to be a
ton of stuff that your doctor does know
about and would be able to point you
toward credible resources on etc etc
i am and i could be wrong about this but
i'm somewhat doubtful
that reproductive medicine doctors are
really watching the literature on
strength and hypertrophy super closely
and so it's it's one of those things
where
that might be kind of a blank spot for
them and very understandably so of the
of the dozens of things you might want
to talk about uh when it comes to family
planning reproductive choices uh various
forms of contraception you know there's
going to be plenty of things that
doctors do need to know a lot about and
conversations they're going to be having
quite frequently in areas of research
they're going to need to stay up to date
on
they're probably not watching the
strength in hypertrophy literature all
that closely um so you know i i think
that that might be a blind spot for some
doctors and so you know when you're
making that decision if potential
impacts on training outcomes is
something that you're concerned about uh
i think that if you
just pulled up a google search or just
scroll down your social media feed for
information on
hormonal contraceptives and their impact
on strength and hypertrophy i think
you'd come across a lot of
scaremongering and a lot of just general
misinformation that is not congruent
with the human evidence um and so yeah i
just wanted to
make that segment uh to help people be
more informed about just that one aspect
of the impact of
of hormonal contraceptives and you know
their potential impact or lack of impact
on strength and hypertrophy outcomes so
people can make informed decisions for
themselves that was that was the whole
purpose of that segment uh the second
thing i wanted to talk about is going
back
oh maybe
maybe three episodes at this point
uh i talked about a meta-analysis
looking at the dose-response
relationship between
resistance training and all-cause
mortality and
various
like ideologies of mortality
and
one of the findings of that
meta-analysis is that there's roughly a
a u-shaped relationship or a j shaped
relationship
where
you know some amount of resistance
training seems to be associated with
increased mortality reductions in
alcohol's mortality and then
if uh if the total amount of training
performed gets high enough then it might
actually be associated with increased uh
all-cause mortality uh and so you know
that was a long segment there were a lot
of rabbit holes we went down a lot of
nuance there i'm not going to rehash all
of that here if you want to listen to
that it's
i'm sure uh
lifting and mortality is is something in
the video title shouldn't be hard to
find
but i wanted to respond to a
a common piece of feedback and a very
understandable piece of feedback that i
got to that segment and that is uh you
know people brought up there are
several meta-analyses at this point and
and just large uh
individual observational studies
finding that
uh higher levels of strength and higher
levels of lean mass or appendicular lean
mass or muscle mass
are all associated with improved
mortality outcomes so you know the the
the question
the obvious question is you know if
being stronger or having more muscle
is predictive of longevity
uh why wouldn't doing a ton of
resistance training to try to build as
much strength and muscle as possible
why wouldn't that also be super
predictive of of uh decreased all-cause
mortality rates like that's that's a
very logical question to ask and i
understand where it's coming from
uh but
first one thing to note
is that this
sort of disconnect also exists within
kind of the cardio and aerobic training
literature where
uh
at least in some context there seems to
be a similar sort of u-shaped
relationship between
the actual cardio people do and
all-cause mortality so this is coming
specifically from the
copenhagen city heart study
where they found that
joggers had lower rates of alcohol's
mortality than non-joggers and uh the
total volume of jogging people did um
doing more and more seemed to generally
be a good thing but the issue was
intensity so if you did quite a bit of
low intensity jogging that was very good
if you did quite a bit of modern
moderate intensity jogging that was
still very good but not quite as good as
doing a whole lot of low intensity
jogging and if you did
quite a lot of high intensity jogging
that was actually associated with
uh
potentially higher
rates of alcohol's mortality so it's the
same general sort of u-shaped
relationship where
you know maybe maybe this thing is good
but maybe it's not so good if you overdo
it um and much like with the findings
that more strength more muscle seems to
be associated with lower rates of
alcohol's mortality we see the same
thing in the aerobic training literature
where people who do have higher levels
of aerobic fitness have considerably
lower rates of alcohol's mortality than
people with lower rates of aerobic
fitness um so you know it's the same
sort of deal where more aerobic fitness
seems to be good but training like an
absolute madman to
doing a ton of super intense jogging
maybe isn't necessarily the best way to
promote uh reductions and i'll cause
mortality uh and i'll also note that the
aerobic training literature and the
strength training literature
um
are similar in so far as the
the outcome of interest so
what is your aerobic fitness how strong
are you how much muscle do you have
seems to be associated with
larger differences in all cause
mortality than the actual training to
promote those things so basically
having
really high levels of aerobic fitness is
predictive of a pretty large reduction
in all-cause mortality
doing aerobic training is associated
with a reduction in alcohol's mortality
but not as large as the reduction uh
observed with simply having really high
levels of aerobic fitness same thing
with resistance training doing
resistance training is associated uh
with reductions and i'll cause mortality
rates but those reductions don't seem to
be as large as the simple difference in
mortality between people who are just
very strong in old age and people who
aren't so
you know the the characteristic is
predictive of
pretty large differences in mortality
the actual training to promote the
adaptations uh related to those physical
characteristics
are also associated with reductions in
all-cause mortality but not as large as
just differences in the characteristic
itself
and so
i think that's worth noting so one like
the the stuff with resistance training
it's it's not just kind of a one-off
thing we see something very similar with
cardio as well um
and i think that
the question raised uh
has a pretty
has at least one
uh
potential and i think very likely answer
so you know if
if being stronger and having more muscle
is predictive of lower rates of
all-cause mortality um you know why
isn't resistance training and as much of
it as possible predictive of
similarly large reductions and i'll
cause mortality and i think that's just
because
when you're dealing with those
characteristics you know not who's
training for what but just simply as
you're entering old age who has higher
aerobic fitness who has more muscle mass
who has more strength
i think that's more just reflective of
genetics but also lifestyle kind of
throughout your entire life so
you know if you're
if you hit like 60 70 you're still you
still have a fair bit of muscle you're
still in pretty good shape
more often than not that means you've
lived a generally healthy generally
active lifestyle up to that point uh and
so you know it's basically it's
basically a question of like
um urge it's a matter of
you know if you're gonna live 80 years
like the first 70 years of your life
that's that's the bulk of your life and
all of the stuff you did during that
time is going to influence how the next
10 15 20 years for you go
versus you know if you lived a generally
inactive not particularly healthy life
for the first 70 years of your life and
you pick up some resistance training
pick up some cardio that is probably
going to be good for you but it and i
certainly wouldn't discourage people
from doing that but it's probably not
going to be quite as helpful as it would
have been
to have been more active for the
previous 70 years and so i think that's
basically what's going on and the other
thing to note
is that
especially for the metas and
in cross-sectional studies that are
looking just at you know do people with
more muscle mass live longer than people
with less muscle mass what what those
studies tend to do is they just uh put
people into quartiles and just compare
between quartiles so how long do people
in the very top quartile of muscle and
strength live versus the people in the
lowest quartile of muscle and strength
and
getting into that top quartile doesn't
require
training like you want to be a
world-class power lifter so just think
about everyone you know in their 60s and
70s uh and just think like hey where
where would the 75th percentile of
muscle and strength fall you know like
probably a very small minority of people
you know who are approximately that age
are still legitimately super strong and
jacked like
you know
most of them like
people people who probably haven't even
lifted weights and are just like kind of
active would probably
be be in that top quartile
um so you know that's what we're talking
about like if you're in decent aerobic
shape you have a decent amount of muscle
you have a decent amount of strength
that tends to be reflective of of living
a pretty good life up to that point
and being in good shape having more
muscle having more strength being
predictive of lower rates of all calls
mortality
doesn't necessarily imply
that training to maximize your aerobic
fitness you know like trying to set the
the marathon world record for people in
the 80 year old age class
or you know trying to absolutely
maximize muscle and strength it's it's
not necessarily implied that you need to
do those things
to reap the longevity benefits of
generally being in good aerobic shape
generally having a decent bit of muscle
generally having a decent bit of
strength like there's
there's that disconnect between the
physical characteristic itself which you
know training does go into but also just
your lifestyle throughout your entire
lifespan and your genetics like all of
those things affect that
versus
just the training component itself so
it's it's logical to assume that if you
train for a
particular physical outcome and that
physical outcome itself is predictive of
all calls mortality the training itself
will be similarly predictive of
shifts in all calls mortality of a
similar magnitude uh but that that just
isn't the case
yeah
those are those are important
clarifications and elaborations uh and i
think the
my main takeaway is if you are
uncomfortable with uncertainty uh
probably best to be a rationalist more
so than an empiricist
because sometimes we get these empirical
findings that come along and you're like
damn
now i got to make sense of all this yeah
and usually the explanation is
a 15-minute talk like that not just like
a two-second like well hey it's good for
your heart well you know so one one
thing i'll point out is you can
you can tell a lot about someone's
biases based on
how they talk about
epidemiological research so you know it
like my my bias is that lifting weights
is [ __ ] good for you and you should
do it and so i
i would love to be able to look at a
meta that shows oh people in the top
quartile of muscle mass tend to live
longer than the people in the lower
lowest quartile of muscle mass
therefore
you know
train like a power lifter and you're
gonna live forever like that
i i would love to be able to make that
leap and in my younger years i probably
have made that leap before um
but you know that that isn't
that isn't reflective of of empirical
reality like you know like my whole talk
was just about there's a difference
between the physical characteristic
having more muscle versus having less
muscle
and
actions you would take to try to move
along that continuum at a particular
point in time like those those are
similar but they're not identical
but if you
if you're willing to assume that they're
the same thing in your you're first
willing to assume that that finding more
muscle uh predictive of lower all cause
mortality than less muscle if you're one
just willing to accept that that is that
that is strictly causal it doesn't even
cross your mind that that might be a
spurious correlation and then you're
willing to jump to the next level of
therefore everyone should be doing as
much resistance training as possible you
know that's
uh that's not necessarily reflective of
the evidence that's reflective of your
biases um
versus you know if if some other you
know maybe you're a fiber skeptic and a
meta comes out saying oh fiber is good
for you uh you know then you're not
you're not going to in interface with
that the same way you're not going to
say oh more muscle mass is is better
than less muscle mass cool that's causal
don't need don't need to investigate
that further oh more fiber better than
less fiber that's that's probably mere
association you need to be careful with
this epi stuff like if if you approach
findings
that agree with your biases and not in
those two very different ways um
you know that
that says more about what you want to be
true than what the science actually says
yeah definitely a good point um now you
mentioned
uh probably nice to exercise throughout
the totality of your life rather than
trying to uh you know crank crank it on
when you're like 75 you know so a
question that we get a lot is something
that i figured we could both offer a
little bit of perspective on i see this
question all the time uh
asked us this question
and it was uh how to encourage people
who don't exercise
to start exercising and maintain it you
know what is the approach to
kind of spurring someone to engage with
exercise whether it's walking running
cycling or strength training
um
now i'm going to sound like
a bit of a broken record here but most
of my answer is going to be
predicated on a general acceptance of
self-determination theory it's a theory
in psychology and just like any theory
in psychology uh there are strengths and
weaknesses so and like evolution it's
just a theory you can't exactly take it
that seriously that's exactly what i'm
what i'm getting at uh and probably the
best analogy i could think of
uh but yeah you know there's all sorts
of competing theories in psychology so i
don't want to the fact that i come back
to it frequently is not to suggest it's
the only theory that describes human uh
thought and behavior
but it is one that resonates with me and
i think is really well constructed and
it does have really strong empirical
support in certain contexts um but
before i get into the self-determination
theory aspects of it the first thing is
if you're going to start encouraging
someone to exercise
um
i think the the most important thing
first of all
is to make sure that you are genuinely
doing it with their best interest in
mind and not with any ulterior motives
so you it it's critically important that
you are
kind of encouraging them to exercise
because it's in their best interest not
because it's in your best interest
because i think if you're trying to get
somebody to exercise but there's any
degree of selfishness or personal
benefit behind that i think you're
likely going to be promoting this
exercise adoption
probably in an unfavorable way so so
that's the first thing is if you're
trying to help someone make sure you're
really trying to help them and not
trying to help yourself in some way
so with that out of the way
uh
now the question is how do we actually
do this effectively and
a kind of broad summary like a very
basic overview of self-determination
theory is that
people generally have this kind of
inherent
intrinsic drive toward
growth and learning and self-improvement
and self-actualization we do have this
kind of drive to learn new things and
acquire new skills and get better and
better and better uh that that is kind
of written in our code but in order for
us to really strive toward goals and
reach toward growth and self-improvement
and self-actualization
we need some basic psychological needs
to be met in order to kind of set the
foundation for that and to really set us
up for success and within this theory
the three main pillars are relatedness
competence and autonomy
so in order for us to start really
making these big goal related strides
towards something uh that's going to be
good for us you know some kind of
self-improvement or self you know growth
or actualization
uh relatedness refers to the fact that
we we want to feel part of something we
want to feel tapped into a community we
want to feel like this means something
outside of just our personal experience
with it uh competence of course means
that we have self-efficacy we feel like
we're actually capable of doing what
we're setting out to do and autonomy
means that we
we have some degree of control over it
we we have the ability to kind of uh set
the trajectory that we're on
and kind of set our own short and
intermediate term goals and determine
how we go about goal striving not just
following instructions so what i would
encourage people oh and i should mention
that one of the huge elements of
self-determination theory is the idea of
motivation and more specifically that
uh there are distinct types of
motivation that fall on a spectrum
so if you
dig into the self-determination theory
literature you'll actually see figures
that show this spectrum or this
continuum of motivation and on one end
it starts with a motivation so just
complete lack of motivation which is
obviously one end of of the spectrum
kind of the most extreme end
on the other end of the spectrum is
intrinsic motivation so so motivation
that is derived from within
and then kind of the middle ground you
know it's better than no motivation but
not as powerful not as effective as
intrinsic motivation in the middle there
you find certain forms of extrinsic
motivation
and that's really important because when
when i see people trying to encourage
others to adopt exercise and engage with
exercise a lot of times i feel like
they're really
they would be much better off if they
had this theory in mind and what i mean
by that is with relatedness a great
thing you can do to help somebody adopt
exercise is
to
let them know that you are on their team
it's a support thing so it's not like if
you don't exercise you let me down it's
more we're in this together i'm here to
support you you can lean on me and i
also think it's important that you offer
up the
uh the idea that you know you may want
some
some support
when you're
starting this process of adopting
exercise and you might not want it to be
me you might want to start exercise in a
group fitness setting or join a club or
a team or hire a coach or hire a trainer
or uh you know any number of ways that
you can have some kind of social group
associated with exercise and the
important thing is if you're really
trying to help someone else don't be
selfish about it and say yeah here's
some relatedness i'm your guy you know
and
your relatedness as it pertains to
exercise is that you rely on me as your
support group
you have to give them the opportunity to
self-select a really effective support
group which can take many different
forms
uh the next thing competence sometimes
i'll see people who say hey
you know you should really be lifting
weights and you should probably be doing
it four times a week and you should
probably doing uh you know a very
specific form of resistance exercise
but they don't give them the tools to
actually feel competent right it's
there a lot of times you see people who
put just kind of shove people into the
deep end and say hey here's a program
it's four days a week half of these are
like olympic lifts or highly skilled
barbell movements anyway good luck and
by the way if you don't adopt this
successfully you kind of suck yeah like
you have to equip people with competence
yeah here here's a program called
starting strength you can learn it from
this book you don't need someone to
teach you and also one of the exercises
is power cleans have fun yeah exactly so
you want to make sure you're fostering
relatedness in a non-selfish way
you want to make sure that you're
fostering competence by either
you know kind of guiding them through it
showing them the ropes equipping them
with resources that really are meeting
them where they're at and not where you
think they ought to be and then the
final thing is autonomy so sometimes
people will say i'm going to provide you
support so there's your relatedness i'm
going to teach you how to do this so
that's competence but also i'm going to
insist that you do everything a very
particular way and what they do there is
they detract from autonomy they don't
say hey there are many ways to engage in
exercise let's explore that entire menu
and you can pick the things that you
like instead it's like hey on tuesdays
we squat and you're squatting with me
and you gotta squat my way and if i like
high bar and you like low bar sorry
you're a high bar squatter you know like
so what what you find is that a lot of
people who have tried this in the past
and failed i think self-determination
theory provides some really clear
examples of why
there is failure there so you you have
to
make sure that someone is able to find a
support group that really resonates and
works for them you have to make sure
that they have opportunities to develop
the competence required to engage and
exercise regularly and you have to offer
them a level of autonomy and
independence so that they can really
start to to kind of foster that
intrinsic motivation but in a lot of
cases you've got people who say no you
have to do it a certain way uh you have
no autonomy because i give you your
programs and there's no idea of
there's not even a concept of intrinsic
motivation
i'm going to tell you what to do so your
motivation comes from me which isn't
extrinsic and you have absolutely no
autonomy in the process so
my answer is like i said first of all
make sure that you are truly operating
with their best interest in mind and not
yours and then lean on some of these
pillars of self-determination theory so
that you can put them in a position to
succeed to develop that intrinsic
motivation and once someone truly feels
a sense of relatedness and they feel
competent and they feel like they have
autonomy and they have
that intrinsic motivation because you've
helped them understand
that this is truly in their best
interest i think that's where it really
sticks
yeah that that was all very good and my
my answer was similar but uh but much
shorter um
just help them find something they like
doing uh because that that accomplishes
most of the intrinsic motivation bit
almost by definition you are
intrinsically motivated to do things you
like and you are not as motivated to do
things you don't like
um
and yeah so
i i do think that there is a tendency
especially among serious lifters to just
assume hey i love lifting uh here's this
person they
either i think they should start
exercising or they think they should
start exercising uh well if i love
lifting everyone must love lifting so
cool you're you're my training partner
now and you know sometimes that click
sometimes it doesn't uh but ultimately
exercise is good if people get moving
that uh
you know that accomplishes like pro
probably 80 of the benefits that you
could at least in terms of like health
and longevity that you could hope to
derive from virtually any form of
exercise like just exercise itself is
great um
so yeah if you can
if you can help someone find something
that they like doing um especially if
they're if they're starting with more of
an extrinsic motivation like you know
maybe uh maybe some blood work came back
and it didn't look good and they're like
oh god i need to do something about this
uh or like you know no judgment maybe
it's more shallow like they can't fit
into some of the clothes they used to
before and they would like to be able to
do that again so they want to exercise
as part of a
of a weight loss type shift in lifestyle
you know those are those are
mostly extrinsic motivations like you're
not really exercising for the sake of
exercising you're exercising because you
see it as a means to an end to
uh get something else or attain
something else so you know that's that's
all well and good for getting your foot
in the door but ultimately like you
mentioned intrinsic motivation far more
powerful far more predictive
of sticking with something long-term so
yeah ultimately the name of the game is
is just helping people
um
just find something that they
legitimately enjoy doing and so a few
different um
a few different axes to consider there
is
one uh you mentioned relatedness i i
think it's important to
um
so i think one important axis to keep in
mind is kind of what i would call a
social axis so some people prefer
exercising alone some people prefer
exercising
with a single partner or a small group
some people enjoy exercising in a larger
class so help people kind of
troubleshoot things along that entire
axis so you know any anything from
lifting alone or going for a jog alone
all the way to
uh you know checking out crossfit or
getting into a big zumba class or
something
you know those are kind of the two
extreme ends of that spectrum
uh
i think that kind of a
i think there's kind of a resistance
versus aerobic type axis where you know
both styles of exercise are good but
something kind of
somewhere along that axis tends to be
just a single individual sweet spot in
terms of what they enjoy
so you know they they can maybe try to
expand their exercise palette once they
find the initial thing that really
clicks for them but you know help them
troubleshoot something along that axis
to try to find something that works well
for them all the way from you know
if you're if you're a sick [ __ ] like me
who likes power lifting or like strong
man style stuff all the way to you know
just just going out jogging biking just
pure aerobic type stuff swimming um you
know with something maybe like
uh like body pump or like circuit
training type classes or crossfit or
something in the middle with kind of a
mix of both and then i think the third
axis to consider is the competitive axis
so
you know how
how intrinsically competitive someone is
i i think can go a long way towards uh
influencing whether exercise is going to
click with them or not so like i
personally am a hyper competitive person
and so
any anything where you're keeping score
that like i don't even have to be good
at it i just have to be able to to be
somewhat competitive and be able to get
some points in i'm gonna [ __ ] love it
it's great um
other people are not like that at all
they want something that is you know if
they're competing they're only competing
against themselves or you know going
even further there's
really no impetus even to compete
against yourself like what would it mean
to compete against your prior best
performance in tai chi like i don't i
don't think that exists um
so yeah uh
you know that that is another
continuum from
forms of exercise that are hyper
competitive maybe joining an adult
sports league
to things that are
not competitive at all you know tai chi
yoga going for a walk and so i think
those are kind of kind of the three axes
on which virtu virtually any type of
exercise would fall and so i think
there's just kind of a basic
troubleshooting process like if you know
this person you might have a decent idea
of like ah what kind of person are they
are are they going to want to be around
a bunch of other people or kind of solo
are they a more competitive person
does it does this person give me runner
vibes or lift or vibes and you know kind
of maybe make the initial suggestion of
like hey i think
this type of thing would work well for
you and then they try it and and then
you can just kind of debrief and talk
about it what did you like what did you
not like uh and you know if you're right
on the first guess cool stick with it
for a while see if
you know it wasn't just a good first
impression but the enjoyment grows and
kind of becomes organic and then they do
just just love it like they legitimately
enjoy it they develop that intrinsic
motivation cool you're good to go if
that's not the case then just kind of
try to figure out kind of along those
axes where it didn't click for them like
you know maybe someone tried a crossfit
class and you know they they enjoyed
what they were doing itself like they
enjoyed the stuff they were actually
doing in the class um
you know they liked that there was a
group of people there like they enjoyed
the social element of it but they just
didn't like how competitive it was then
you could say like oh well maybe try a
body pump class like it's kind of the
same thing there's a resistance
component a cardio component you're
doing it with a group of people but it's
not as as directly competitive you know
so so you can just kind of you know
debrief chat and and troubleshoot from
there and try to help them find
something they enjoy doing and then once
once they find something they like um
you know that that's not a perfect
guarantee they're gonna stick with it
forever but that is a pretty strong
predictor that they will stick with it
at least for a while and you know even
if they kind of fall out of love with
that initial form of exercise in the
first place maybe by that point they've
built just a habit of exercising they've
developed more self-efficacy and they
kind of feel more for themselves like
they can start uh troubleshooting and
trying new things that that clicks with
them better now
yeah those are great uh great additions
very practical i think the one
elaboration that's really helpful is
related to
relatedness so the way i framed it made
it seem like working out with one person
is kind of related working out with two
is more related and working out with 10
is even is even better but you're very
correct in the sense that relatedness
can take many different forms so some
people may prefer to work out alone
but may also have the ability to pursue
relatedness through just having someone
to
talk to about how their process is going
or joining a supportive facebook group
or subreddit where they can kind of see
that other people are navigating the
same experience or
independently training for a competition
and just feeling like no what i'm doing
is actually in pursuit of being part of
this competitive community you know so
that can take a lot of different forms
and you mentioned your competitiveness
people have accused me of not being
competitive
because
if i like play a board game or like
we're just like shooting hoops or
something i'll seem very aloof and just
not really that into it uh
and that is fully a protective mechanism
because i am too competitive
and so like from what when i decide i'm
going to be competitive about something
it's for all the marbles so like growing
up i was like i think i'm kind of
competitive about like
you know educational attainment and i
was like dude i'll go to college for 10
years
i'll do it and i don't think you will
you know like it and same thing like
with bodybuilding i was like i'll starve
to death i'll go all the way dude like
i will
and like yeah i got to the point where
like the people in my department were
asking if i was okay
not asking me asking around
you know like people were like hey is is
everything all right with that guy and
then it got it kind of got back to me so
like yeah i'm so competitive that i
cannot allow myself to compete unless
i'm willing to
really have a brush with death over it
basically yeah really leave your body on
the field but but in a literal sense
exactly yeah
um all right so i think that does it for
this episode but to play us out i just
have a friendly reminder uh you know we
are
i believe still the first and only uh
family values christian conservative
podcast uh in the fitness world
and i just want to remind everybody that
we are in fact
given uh
current events going on in the world
that it might have to drop
at least for a bit yeah yeah it's a
little bit too close to home but yeah i
did just want to facetiously remind
everybody that we are in fact sinners in
the hands of an angry god uh i'm
repenting to try to get ahead of this uh
so basically the context is
in 2013 my house was struck by lightning
er just a couple days ago a tree fell on
my house
and so called fake news meteorologists
will have different explanations for
what's going on but
i i think i know what's happening here i
think these severe acts of weather
happening in such close proximity to my
home is a clear warning sign uh and i'm
worried about it but but like i said i'm
i'm repenting basically hourly trying to
get ahead of this thing so that um
hopefully no more natural disasters uh
attack me in my home
and i would encourage everyone to do the
same well i am i am hoping for the best
for you thank you i have too little to
play us out uh related things so in the
last episode talked about sumo and
conventional deadlift a little bit uh i
shouted out jeff nippard's recent video
on the topic
but what i didn't mention
was the best practical tip from that
video
that he didn't even verbalize but that i
saw and i was like what the [ __ ] can you
do that so there's a shot in that video
of jeff eating what else a kiwi guy
loves kiwis but he didn't peel it he
just bit into it like an apple and
i thought like
whoa is is this a bit is he doing a
character like he was kind of trying to
play
like a
like an unhinged bad cop bad cop uh type
type skit with uh a cardboard cutout of
sebum so i was like maybe this is just a
part of like his unhinged interrogator
character yeah or maybe it's a real
thing maybe you can just bite into a
kiwi and you don't have to peel it and
uh yeah tried it recently you [ __ ]
can you don't need to peel kiwis which
was wild to me i had no idea i thought
that the skin was inedible but like it's
not it's kind of you know it's kind of
fuzzy it's not the most pleasant texture
but you can bite through it easily
enough and as soon as you start chewing
like you just don't notice it anymore
and the thing is i really like kiwis but
i never ate them just because they were
such a pain in the ass to peel so now
that i know that i can just eat kiwis
like apples
that's incredible that that opens up uh
one new dietary horizon for me which is
eating more kiwis
yeah i had no idea
that's incredible now you know i got to
get on that the other thing that i
wanted to mention to play us out uh is
so
uh lindsay and i went to a to a concert
this past weekend
and i caught
a very small snippet of conversation
between two of the ushers and i don't
know what the context for this was i
don't know what became what came before
or after it but i i heard this one
phrase and in ruminating about it i
realized that it's probably completely
banal
but it might be one of the most
sinister standalone phrases in the
english language and that's just you
know these two you know seemingly nice
innocuous ushers were talking to each
other and one of them says to the other
we'll outnumber them soon
and i don't know what the context for
that is but the thing is there there are
a lot of places that phrase could go
that are very scary i can't think of a
good one yeah so uh
anyway i just the only time i can think
of a good one is if you're playing a
game of dodgeball i guess yeah or like
red rover yeah but yeah and it was very
it was very weird because like they
like they did just seem like very
pleasant so i assumed that it was
nothing scary but
i mean it was the same as you i was
going through through it in my head like
we'll outnumber them soon
what what good uh situations would you
say would you say that in that like in
almost all regards that's hostile
takeover language like we're going to do
something to another group of people who
can currently resist it but soon they
will be unable to withstand our
onslaught like that's that's kind of the
vibe so i i just wanted to to leave you
with that thought
is that like a warning
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what they were talking about all right
well on one of the more sinister notes
we've ever hit on the podcast i think
that's probably a good way to close it
and we'll give everyone a week to to
think about that right
uh so as always thank you so much for
joining us and we will be back soon with
another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of the stronger by
science podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you